tonight on Hotel Hell I head to a
Pennsylvania in is the reception who
delusional owner I want what I want I
know what I want has completely
neglected it oh look at those bugs
cockroach to welcome me on the toilet
having a number two way I'm just like I
can't believe it and what I discover
will make you sick to your stomach
unfuckingbelievable has this thing ever
been washed I don't even like to think
of what I'm looking at this is truly
disgusting that's not an in it's a
[__]
disaster
[Music]
two years ago chef and restaurant tour
Ken PES had a dream he bought the river
rock in in Milford Pennsylvania a
Charming Town nestled in the stunning
Pocono Mountains just 2 hours drive from
Manhattan it was a golden opportunity
light sh of bomans had come this
way but soon after he got the keys the
dream turned into a nightmare I was
expecting to reach a certain number on
room sales and I didn't hit one tenen of
that I don't I think Kenny has an ideaa
how to run an inn and the few guests
that do come are far from impressed
there's nothing in the bathroom no
shampoo no conditioner soap nothing we
have to go out and buy some if I came in
I would probably check right back out it
was like old it's trying to be cozy but
it's not it's hideous if I wanted to
stay at my grams I could pack a bag and
go stay at my grams I'm not going to a
B&B for that if you buy an in you got to
step up and be an in keeper we need to
fill these rooms we really do facing
financial disaster Ken was forced to
move out of his house and into the Inn I
said Ken you're making the biggest
mistake and he moved in and he turned in
a miserable man Ken is now 48 Single
Living in his crumbling in and hundreds
of thousands of dollars in debt the more
the hotel fails
$2,868 and taxes that are still do the
more controlling Ken
becomes he just takes everything out on
us to make our lives feel miserable just
like his you don't feel very good about
yourself as an employee kind of chips
away at your sense of self I I don't
know what's going on I I told you I'd
buy a little time so I's down here
everybody's walking on eggshell
everybody's afraid to do their job they
don't want to get yelled at clip come
here [__] everybody threatens to quit
it's a daily event yeah if things don't
get better here I'm definitely leaving
you know what you really need to grow up
and at your age you're a 48-year-old man
just get the [__] out of my face the
progression of events has just turned it
all into a hot mess and it doesn't
matter what we do it's just a hot
flipping
[Music]
mess River Rock in an American Beast way
wow all right where's the
[Music]
reception right anyone
in it's like a hallway not a checking
desk unless she's behind there hello
hello somebody's ashes are down there
bloody
hell just L my granddad's house
hello where's the reception uh this is
it basically the reception should be out
in a minute if you like I'll re it for
you thank you very much well hello nice
to see you it's nice to see you I'm
Karen Lo and it's a pleasure to meet you
I'm a little bit nervous then you know
you were nervous yeah honestly because I
was just like standing here on my own oh
well I'm sorry I apologize for that um
it's confusing where's the reception
desk it's right here this is the
reception desk can I just quickly show
you something
yes I know I don't mind getting stuck in
well oh dear oh dear that is pretty bad
yeah that's not very pleasant that's not
at all
Pleasant uh so would you like to go to
your room uh yeah follow me this way
okay how old is this place this hotel
was built around 1880s I think it was
decorated in 1880 as well it kind of
looks that way for the first time and
the last time it's been a while for the
rooms there is a closet over over here
are they special hangers just for me oh
yep wow w wow I think the coat will
stay what is
that extra extra carpeting we just got
new carpeting here okay so it's uh save
for repairs I've never had free carpet
in my wardrobe before okay just check my
view look at those bugs and the blue
bottle is stain for the
week there's like a little Forest of
them down here we give these to your
cleaner
sorry it's like an insect
funeral truthfully in the fall there was
like a ladybug problem you bringing an
in guest and oh my gosh there'd be like
you know 50 bugs in the room and so Ken
and I would take care of that to get rid
of the ladybugs for the people to stay
um now they've died and look at this
here I think that's a cockroach to
welcome me on the toilet having a number
two I'm just like I can't believe it
look at that never had a cockroach
committee welcome me on the John let's
get out of here well what else is on
this floor well this is the owner's
quarters and all these bits of furniture
here do people literally sit that seems
to work well to for Internet service out
here okay so this is the Wi-Fi chair yes
it really is I'm going to bear that in
mind if I need to check my
emails it's very sketchy at best okay
far worse than I thought through
Gordon's eyes I was like wo it's is
totally neglected now I will uh I'll
unpack and get ready for dinner
[Music]
okay welcome to Milford it's a joke had
it go it was horrible the place is
filthy
filthy my first impressions of the in
have been Dreadful at least I can take
my mind off things with some TV nothing
look at that I knew those shitty hangers
would come in useful for something
[__] come on can't believe I'm going
to miss The Simpsons come on
damn this is embarrassing $110 for this
[__] hole just the general hygiene
cleanliness is just
shocking the Wardrobe is full of crap
and there's no excuse for dead insects
and filth everywhere it's like they've
given up and no one knows there's a
hotel here because it's just not
fit to rent these rooms out for the
public I mean look at
it this is what the bedrooms are like
God knows what dinner's going to be
like so far at Milford Pennsylvania's
River Rock in I've discovered outdated
Decor bugs Galore look at that I've
never had a cockroach committee welcome
me on the John and a TV that last worked
in
1982 I've heard that the owner is a chef
so maybe the restaurant will be the
river Rock's Saving Grace
okay
good to see you to meet you and it's Ken
isn't it yes sir is American beastro
outside yes is it a classic beastro is
it yes everything made from scratch
that's nice you're a chef by trade yes I
am are you not in the Kitchen Tonight uh
no I'm not working on a line so you've
retired from cooking somewhat running
the past maybe or I'm running the other
side I'm just watching all the food and
letting sting everything out it's hard
to run this whole place by yourself I
have so many years of experience I
thought that when he hired me he'd be
able to let go a little bit in KN way
that I could get this job done but he
just can't seem to let go um and how
would you rate the food 1 to 10 seven or
eight and if I asked you to rate your
rooms out of 10 what would you give them
four or five I'm now [__] myself
about dinner let's hope that the food is
better than the rooms
sure the concept of an American beastro
serving fresh local food in a country in
makes perfect sense but I can't make any
sense of this menu um so I'm getting a
little bit confused cuz we've gone
Mexican on the quad DEA we've jumped
down to isand and then we got an Italian
for the
calamari what what American be yes you
wow um what would you recommend on the
menu we do a house smoke trout I believe
that it's a golden trout from uh
Northern California comes in Frozen
you're recommending that I eat frozen
trout from Northern California you know
Chef it it it it's it's been only Frozen
Once your head is sweating it's a little
hiot in here sir you're dripping it's me
I'm sorry sh I feel like I a leak in my
[__] B your bald head who puts these
ideas together that would be Kenny
show okay um so give me a taand players
yes sir yeah uh entree dying to see
that I'm traveling around the globe in
Milford enjoy I'm appalled I was
promised an American beastro instead I
get a sampling from around the world I
was expecting fresh food but I get
recommended frozen fish what's going on
here you're Tai sampler
Chef are they made in house no they are
not no thank you James
[Music]
wow it's just Frozen cramp reheated and
how can you make slice of chicken look
so Bland I wouldn't give that tie
experience to my [__]
dog L6 is on the fire too James I'm
struggling yes sir where's the chef from
is he a local boy yes he is I think left
to his own devices he do very well he's
very limited on what he can use for
ingredient wise because he doesn't do
the shopping who does the shopping now
Kenny does the shopping so he's almost
like cut the balls of the chef off yes
sure M6 M14 menu at the river rock is
pretty much outdated uh it's Kenny's
menu it's been here few years I don't
agree with the menu but it's he's my
boss he pays my my salary and still you
know get to that point where it just
kind of burnt
[Music]
out hi Gordon Amry how are you tough on
this one what did you do here I bartend
and I help manage Ken's the chef and the
chef that's cooking is not allowed to
cook his own dishes yeah it's almost
like he's sort of cut his balls off well
it's kind of what he does with all of us
oh really he deflet you strips your
confidence won't let you make any
decisions executive or otherwise that's
crazy and it's it's a lot of
micromanagement why' you stay here and
I'm a loyal dog unfortunately I'd bend
over backwards for him but I'm that
Bone's wearing
thino that's your Chef Ramy that might
be the golden
ticket thank you thank you Jesus Christ
almighty it's like someone's just
dropped a [__] T-Rex foot on my
plate holy that's the valano chef
honestly in fact that might be a small
valdano Chef oh that's a small one yes
sir I mean it's like a meal for eight
that valdano can feed an Ethiopian
family of 40 you know what I mean
horrific this is not what I would expect
in a country in it's worse than a nasty
Road Diner I feel like I'm eating a
[__] flip-flop with
mayonnaise Ken the owner looks like a
zombie sleep walking towards disaster
it's time to get everyone together and
see if I can wake Ken up how much money
are you losing per month right now about
5 to 7,000 a month and that's on the
decline correct if those rooms aren't
that busy why are they so disgustingly
dirty
they they they're dirty because I didn't
check them it's almost like we're
robbing
customers when I arrived you gave your
food seven or eight out of 10 yes but
the food was
Dreadful Seth how long you been cooking
almost 18 years as a chef 18 years in
the business are you proud of what you
serve personally I don't it's Kenny's
menu it's on the menu so I want what I
want I know what I want you can't hold
people's hands in this business
if you don't fix this in they've all
lost their
job I honestly think that Kenny needs
somebody to open his eyes so that he can
see that everybody that works for him is
capable and we're dependable and we're
here to help him increase his business
and make it successful and nobody scared
hurt him I'm here to
help it's impossible cuz you are not
helping
yourself and it's not as if you're the
captain of the Titanic you're the
[__]
Iceberg yet you you haven't stared at
yourself long enough in the mirror and
actually understood where the issues are
you're looking at
them good
night [__]
me
Jesus I've had about all I can take for
one
day it's time to get to bed but based on
how nected these rooms are I need to
know exactly what I'm sleeping on my
black light will reveal any bodily
fluids previous guest have left behind
off on the
bed oh Jesus Christ that has got to be
Sean this is Hotel
Hell before my first night sleeping at
the river rock in in Milford
Pennsylvania I decided to check it out
with my black light to make sure there
was nothing I wasn't
seeing and I was appalled to discover a
vast spread of bodily fluid stains has
this thing ever been washed people pay
to sleep in this bed un [__]
believable there is no way I'm sleeping
on these sheets tonight luckily I came
[Music]
prepared oh [__] I forgot to turn off
the
[Music]
lights oh man that was
rough hopefully a sh will wash away the
memory of those a
stains [__] look at this
thing [__] me it's like being in Danny
DeVito's house a
shower come
on I feel dirtier now than I did before
I got in here
[__] it's
freeing I don't think the staff or the
owner have any idea how revolting it is
to be a guest here I want you to come
upstairs with me I want to show you
something place all of you time for a
wakeup
call good morning good morning these are
the guests that have been staying in the
hotel now you've all experience over the
last 24 hours a sleepover and what I'm
here to do is to help fix this place I
can't do it without your
feedback my biggest complaint was this
morning when I took a shower um I had
water up to my ankles before I got out
my shower head I probably showered from
here down cuz the shower head hit me
about here there was like bugs on the
floor and then I was sitting on the bed
and then I saw a bug on the door too I
have back problems and this morning it
was really hard to get out of bed um
just cuz you could feel the
Springs the big question for me is that
on the back of last night's experience
who would stay here
again a little raise of
hands I probably wouldn't come to stay
again really no
[Music]
one thank you very much indeed thank you
thank you I hope Ken is starting to see
how his lack of effort at the Inn is
driving guest away there's one more
thing I want to show him if this doesn't
wake him up nothing will I'm going to
show you something that is pretty
horrific come in uh just stand over
there please 3 of
you
glasses
on brace yourself
[Music]
Karen oh my
goodness I'm disgusting it's awful I
don't even like to think of what I'm
even looking at it's like a [__]
Galaxy this is foul absolutely foul I'm
CH shocked a little bit it's disgusting
it's truly disgusting the seeing this
makes me sick to my stomach oh dear I
don't know what to say I mean I'm just
it it's a horror
show it was horrifying I was thinking
how many times have this room even been
rented without being cleaned for all
that to be there Ken you're running a
[__] hotel not a brothel it is
[__] disgusting start taking
responsibility I've discovered some
disgusting things at the river rock in
horrific food I would give that to my
[__] dog dead bugs it's like an
insect funeral home and I've worked out
what the source of all the problems is
it's Ken and it's not as if you're the
captain of the Titanic you're the
[__]
[Music]
Iceberg he's in way over his head and
making everyone's life miserable as a
result and his incompetence has let the
Inn fall into a shocking
State it's like a [__] Galaxy it's
awful I even like to think of what I'm
even looking at this is truly
disgusting it's a true slap in the face
I apologize to everybody who slept there
before that I put you through that I
think it's
horrible I hope Ken realizes now that
there's more to running an inn than just
owning an
inn this place needs to change and
change
fast yes we need B at least just wait to
get some first up the Inn needs to be
cleaned so it's a place fit for paying
guests to stay in I put the whole team
to work to clean the Inn from top to
bottom and I'm going to address the
worst problem myself hello Madam Hi how
are you very well thank you is there any
chance I can put this through a
wash yes when do you need it by by
tonight that's definitely you mind but
could you do a sort of extra strong
cleaning product it's pretty
rancid okay so be careful we'll be done
thank you bye-bye careful we don't catch
[Music]
anything wow place is looking so fresh
while the staff finished cleaning the
Inn I want to have a snoop around the
kitchen and see if there's any more
clues as to how Ken is running this
place notes everywhere who writes notes
like this why do I have to ask weakly
for the fish to be IED down do not take
this sign down do not take my pens by
your own if you use this drill replace
it or I'll buy a new one with your
paycheck bloody hell
Charming Ken definitely has issues
bloody cow if you eat these cookies take
one to your next job
interview I mean my God I'm surprised
anyone still [__] works here this guy
is incredible that's not
management this is insane I can't
believe Ken is so passive aggressive
with his staff I need to talk to him and
find out what the hell is going on I
come across all these little notes about
don't take this if you do take it to
your next interview you tell me what's
going
on I I don't like being taken advantage
of I have some hard times with things
that they
do but why aren't you talking to them
why aren't you leading them why aren't
you motivating them why aren't you
getting close to
them the secret of any good management
is about communication understanding and
putting yourself on their level maybe I
I look at it as they should be on my
level who you
kidding come with me I want to show you
something take a seat here Ken thinks
he's managing his staff but I think he's
bullying them he needs to see how he's
making them feel I've set up a monitor
in one of the bedrooms and I'm going to
force Ken to watch a staff meeting I
think this might bring about the change
this place desperately needs stay here
I'll be back in
[Music]
5 I came here to
help what I'm frustrated about is what
I'm discovering I snooped around the
kitchen I come across
this a cookie
jar if you eat these cookies take one to
your next job
interview we call those Kenny's nasty
grams I mean is this a joke or is this
no that's real I put those notes up
because my staff needs reminders for me
to tell them to do the simplest task
they can come off as degrading but I
don't know if they get the hint the any
other way what in the hell is going on
look at this one don't take my pens by
your own I think he hides behind he's
afraid of Confrontation it's passive
aggressive Seth how how does that make
you feel he causes us all to be
discouraged in the job set we have
there's so many people here that really
know their jobs well but we have become
discouraged and when people become
discouraged they don't do the things
that are
[Music]
necessary there's no gratitude like so
when you say to us why why are we like
this we're just spiritless he's really
just sucked the Soul at every one of
us he's just a spirit sucker
honestly
I've locked Ken the owner of milford's
river rock in into a bedroom where he
can watch a staff meeting on TV if you
eat these cookies take one to your next
job interview the staff have told me his
management style has destroyed their
morale is this a joke is this that's him
real every day there's no gratitude like
so when you say to us why why are we
like this we're just spiritless he's
really just sucked the soul out of every
one of us individually over the period
and length of time he's just a spirit
sucker
honestly amar's comments about me
brought tears to my eyes her especially
because she's one of my closest friends
did hurt me what do you want to see
change from him let the people his team
do the work that he's hired us to do
this place can succeed providing that
you stay on track you've got to stand up
to
him let me go and get him
I hope that seeing that finally got
through to Ken it's time to reveal to
the staff that he was upstairs watching
every word wow of what my staff thinks
about me it's
Awakening it it really saddens me
because I would do anything for them and
I feel that they don't see
that I need to
change I uh watched everything you said
and I
apologize I never wanted to suck the
life out any of you and uh think I
control this place but realize maybe I
don't need to
control you have a good team here and if
we are going to move
forward you have to give them ownership
of their own areas uh Seth yep you've
got to get that mojo back and I'm
falling back in love with what you've
employed to
do uh Karen uh you care and that's what
being a good in keeper that little
Personal Touch mhm you should have a a
hold on the inside of this business as
sort of filling the place like the in
hotel manager so I want you to have that
level of
[Music]
responsibility I think what I learned
the most was that I need to give people
the opportunity to run this place I
can't micromanage like I always did I
really hope that he backs off and lets
us all do our jobs he just has to put
the faith in us and I know that our team
can accomplish
[Music]
anything I think Ken's warming to the
idea of change but I don't feel I've got
to the heart of why he looks like a man
under such extreme
pressure Kenny have you got 2 minutes
sure thing come in come on in there's
got to be more to this than
Mone yesterday in many ways I started to
believe You' you'd given up today we
turned the corner we've got to stay on
that track I thought I I thought I could
control this place and it didn't work
mhm it's not working it seems like the
pressure you're under is not just
Financial right in order to buy this
place I borrowed from my brother I said
I think I can really make this work and
and the price is Affordable would you
help me after we met with the
owners he went to the truck and says how
much you want me to write the check out
for wow wow he's my
idol and my mother too my mother it
wouldn't happen without her help either
I said I could move to this Restaurant
to this place and the only way I could
do it is I need some money from you I
needed
$50,000 and she also said just take
it so both their houses are tied into
here
so if this place fails you have let them
down and
yourself this entire place wouldn't be
here without my brother and my mother's
help I want the business to succeed so
they don't have to have a worry I don't
want to ever let them down and you can't
do it alone yeah I know do you have a
girlfriend in here or no no don't take
this the wrong way but it needs a it
needs a woman's touch it needs a bit of
a feminine approach needs that kind of
love no yes it's been kind of rough
there's been no lady in my life because
I haven't been had a chance to go out
there and and even meet or date women I
just want to meet that special person
and just big deep
breath it's the first time I smiled in a
while
[Music]
good the river rock in has come a long
way from where we started the one's
filthy in is now clean and Ken the owner
has seen the error of his ways I
apologize
I never wanted to suck the life at any
of you but before this place is ready to
welcome guest the staff need to
understand the true meaning of
hospitality this place is definitely on
the road to recovery but I think this
team needs some training so I've asked a
very special friend rames sedani from
Caesar's
Palace can actually show them how it's
done hi Gordon good to see you how are
you well I'm de thank how are you I'm
great please take a seat it's so nice to
see you it's great to see you so the
customer focus is critical isn't it very
much and in your mind what are the
golden rules on in the first 60 seconds
you have to approach a guest with a big
smile on your face because that just
opens all kinds of doors find little
ways to to make a lasting impression on
that guest and let them know that their
comfort and their enjoyment is your
primary objective and it sounds simple
but it's not that simple is it if you
practice all the basics the rest of it
will just fall into place it has to be
natural people know when you're not
being sincere the good news is the team
here you know their heart is in the
right place but they are clearly lacking
training the owner doesn't smile that
often so okay all right let me go get
the team okay thanks for mesh Kenny we
got someone U very special I want to
introduce you to please come through I'd
like to introduce you to a very uh very
dear friend of mine please my name is
rames rames very nice to meet you he's
from Caesar palace he's flown in from
Vegas I asked raes to come and teach you
how to greet customers holy mackerel
he's the guy that runs Caesar's Palace
coming to teach my staff how lucky of a
guy am I he's here to help you and to
show you within 60 seconds of those
guests arriving through that door what
we need to hit First Impressions go
wrong they never forget it okay why
don't we have a look at what they
normally do stop straight away and we
restart okay
okay stop as soon as you see a guest
coming through there you can come out
here and reach for the door open the
door and have a big smile on your face
it look like you just lost your
arm here we
go
bollocks okay put a lot more into it
okay it's got to be good afternoon it's
great to have you here welcome it was
kind of hard I'm going to work to get
better at greeting people good afternoon
nice to have you here welcome to the
river rock in thank you very much stop
before he accepted ends his hand out to
you you should have extended your hand
out to him I feel like I'm being yelled
at by a drill sergeant you're out on the
stairs Taren your turn Karen you have an
incredible smile that was a little
nervous Gordon's in the back and he's
chanting you know you could do this you
could do this you know and give it a pep
talk here we
[Music]
go good afternoon I'm Karen Welcome To
The River Rock good afternoon my name is
James San Filippo I'm here to check in
welcome Mr San Filippo come right this
way I see that you'll be staying with us
for the next week yes ma'am possibly
more of of course that would be
wonderful uh we have you staying in our
KingSize room which is on the second
floor absolutely lovely room with a
pretty view out the front of the house
so that's a nice place to be
nice
finally amazing Karen is a super star
she really is that was very well done
Gordon helped me realize that I have
people that I can rely on and instead of
being the Hands-On owner I should be
more of the overseeing owner which I
really need to be very well done very
[Music]
well now that rsh has taught the staff
how to make the right first impression
I'm going to try and help Ken boost his
self-esteem which will make him a much
better inkeeper Ken meet Barbie Barbie
meet Ken nice to meet you nice to meet
you I've flown in Barbie hatch a
Hollywood stylist to give him a new look
this one's a little bit too big for you
a different shirt maybe of while Barbie
gets to work on transforming Ken I want
to check out the in's website Wii and
see if that's also in need of a makeover
okay this is supposed to be the Wi-Fi
chair and I can't even get any
signal
[__] [__] one
bar there's amazing competition in this
town so in order to stand out and sort
of be somewhat different you do need a
great
website my goodness the opening page on
the website looks as old and frumpy as
the interior of the bedrooms I mean so d
it's like he's been put together on a
$20 budget shocking he obviously doesn't
realize that 80% of hotel bookings are
done online today so if you've got no
decent website to follow then you're
absolutely screwed uh come back to me
signal let's see it's great it really
works you don't have to put on a park it
just throws around your neck you're done
let's do it thank you so much you're so
welcome Ken's makeover is finished and
I'm going to take him out on the town
but first let's see what his staff think
your new inke
keeper very very nice yeah yes very
handsome let's
[Music]
go I'm taking Ken to a local bar I think
that meeting the right girl will give
him a great confidence boost the sort of
positive energy that will light up the
river rock and make Ken a pleasure to
deal
with what a Lely little place take a
seat
how Dapper does Kenny look look very
Dapper he does doesn't he Thank you
new how could that man still be single
sing Kenny single oh we got to find you
a milk we do
know really do invite her for dinner
tomorrow tomorrow at River Rock in yes
tomorrow night yes we launching
tomorrow tomorrow night going to be
awesome so can we have a little toast to
Kenny finding a
girlfrien come on girlfriend it was it
was really great Eagle boost I felt like
the king boy he really set me
up thank you very much if I fail now I'm
really a
loser big day tomorrow see in the
morning that's for she good night thank
you good
night honestly I've never seen a man
change so much um let's just hope he's
not late for breakfast in the morning
cheers to K cheers to Kenny ladies
my design team worked through the night
to transform Milford Pennsylvania's
River Rock in and now it's time to
reveal the changes to Ken and his team
good morning good morning how are we
very good good Seth how you feeling
great great excellent all of you this
week have really put so much effort into
get this in back on track so I'm greatly
appreciative for your efforts it's only
fitting okay that we start the relaunch
with a proper sign take a look at
this it's not the old sign from the old
restaurant it's a beautiful sign River
Rock in and restaurant the best food and
lodging in the Pok how cool is that
that's very cool does it look nice
beautiful it's wonderful thank you okay
ready to go inside yeah excited let's go
come through are you ready it's a
beautiful place to live and stay oh my
not a place you got to come and
die first off we have a stunning color
on the walls G is at hideous paper so
now it's in keeping with a rustic charm
and all the bugs are gone too the
changes are just incredible I'm I'm a
bit overwhelmed by them I'm Blown Away
totally Blown Away we replace that
dinosaur TV with a new flat screen guess
what it works okay replacing the
mattresses stunning linen oh my goodness
new table lamps and guess what gone
other spunk stains Karen the only Milky
Way from the skies above
yes Karen it's what do you think I I
think it's absolutely beautiful it's
still a country end but it's a country
end of the year
2012 let me show you the room next door
please this is
incredible this is just amazing Gordon
just did wonders here oh by the way what
I've updated your router okay so you
have have Wi-Fi in in the room inside
the room oh my God how cool is that
amazing hello I'm Blown Away you're
Blown Away Blown Away excellent oh wow
please come in wow look at this come in
come in come
in when I first arrived the checking was
so confusing now the guests come in they
sit down we offer them A coffee glass of
water and then we'll go to actually
booking
in
[Laughter]
online how cool is that that is is easy
now how much do you spend on linen a
month a fortune a fortune underneath
tablecloths you had these stunning
natural tables which were just been
hidden at a ridiculous expense focus on
the linen upstairs in the room before
Gordon was here I just had a restaurant
now I have an inn I have a destination I
can't wait I'm looking forward to the
relaunch tonight we're going to have a
lot of fun you like it thank you yeah
you like it
man with a new decco and R's expert
training hello welcome to the river rock
I'm Karen along with a newly inspired
Ken nice to see you how you been enjoy
your dinner thank you the river rock is
in a much better place time to go when I
got here Ken honestly that guy was a
hopeless inkeeper almost like someone
had given up but you with turned him
around it's almost like he's sort of
he's got his mojo back and now a river
rock has every chance of succeeding but
I tell you what I've seen a lot of Skies
but not quite a Milky Way like that [__]
me as I prepare to leave guests are
arriving for the relaunch and I noticed
some familiar faces from the bar last
night and as promised they've brought a
friend how are you my dumy nice to meet
you oh you're the
D have a little peep have a little peep
have a little peep First Impressions he
looks cute looks
cute
nice I can feel a good night coming
[Music]
on Joey I need three onion soups two
fish cakes and fish fingers with can
trusting his staff and not micromanaging
he's able to spend more time on the
floor salute my friends leaving time to
charm the mil of Milford hello how's
everyone tonight welcome and this is hi
K nice to meet you ni to meet you follow
me voice is come on wake
up I was excited to see them she was
very pretty I look forward to talking
with her here we go ladies I thank you
so much salute my first impressions of
Ken he looks cute U very gentlemanlike
we'll see how the night goes salute
ladies thank you very
[Music]
much the Inn is buzzing and Ken's
invited some very special guests to see
the place at its best and this is my
brother oh how are you sir likewise good
to see you too and my mother hello Madam
how are you are you very well thank you
nice to meet you there's no words to
express how proud I am of D upstairs the
guests are loving the new rooms and
downstairs they're loving the fresh
local menu that Chef Seth and I put
together really really
good really
good before I can leave there's one last
thing I need to take care of can I have
your cell number please not for me for
Ken come on thank
you amazing listen thank you so much for
coming tonight I really
appreciate thank you Ken come here okay
now how you feeling I feel wonderful
honestly at the beginning of the week I
thought you going to sort of almost I
suppose fall to the Wayside but you
bounce back and I'm grateful for that
thank you I'm grateful for you oh and
one more
[Music]
thing Kim sound number it's for you I
can't have a better wingman and Gordon
Ramsey holy [__] he gave me a number
it's in my
pocket no more sticky notes nothing let
them do it yeah
okay I love you this is your greatest
thank you so much Gordon made me realize
that I should be less of the Hands-On
owner who can't see the forest Through
the Trees from here on I'm empowering my
staff to make their own decisions and
I'm going to support them no more more
micromanaging for
me what a week what a
Galaxy [__] me tonight on Hotel Hell I'm
trying to breathe life back into a
historic country in yeah [__] the
hotel's arrogant owner Robert Dean the
second I've always thought you should
live with nice things if you can afford
them treats the Inn like his personal
castle and treats his loyal staff with
disdain go on then you pump as [__]
excuse me don't talk to me like that but
what's wrong with it is this hotel
beyond my help I'm barely surviving
financially and emotionally I mean I'm
going to lose
[Music]
everything
the historic Juniper Hill Inn sits on a
Hilltop above the quain village of
Windsor Vermont built in 1902 the
country Mansion Bo 28 luxurious
bedrooms and two grand dining rooms it
is filled with original works of art and
antiques all museum quality antiques
dealer Robert Dean II and his boyfriend
Ari Nikki bought the business six years
ago I've always thought that you should
live with nice things if you can afford
them good there R I thought you'd like
it the guests that we don't want here
are people who don't have a lot of money
the in may look the part but despite
Robert's dreams of an elite country
estate the hotel is barely functioning
Robert Dean has no hotel or no
restaurant experience the pr is may be a
little bit high for locals $350 two
night minimum so that's $700 the lack of
communication is very frustrating where
are you I know the customers see that
every day I need my key too I at this
point I can't even get in my room okay
with bookings at an all-time low the
hotel is in serious financial
trouble but that doesn't stop Robert
from living a Millionaire's dream Robert
believes this place is his
playground and the playground for his
friends he's got to have a lot of
clothes made
[Laughter]
by he comps all their meals and rooms
but we never get tips they're having a
hard time paying me because they give
away all of their money and food to
their friends showing off using this as
their private castle with hardly any
paying guess it's no wonder that this
Inn is in the red yes we are losing
money more or less like $200,000 a year
I think that the place is going to be
closed and it's that's very sad Gordon
is going to come into this place and say
this place is [__] if I don't stop
this business from bleeding
money it's
doomed I'd love to own an inn in a
setting like this if you get it right
you'd make an absolute Fortune before I
get to Juniper Hill I want to find out
what the town's folk think of the local
in hello how are you very well and
yourself yeah well you I've been driving
all morning um how's Juniper hell in
you're going to love it it's beautiful
um reputation it tends to be a little on
the high end for our area okay but I
would love to have a place to go to
locally do they not invite locals up
there I feel um that I'd be interrupting
I feel like I'd be intruding are you
really what a shame thank you so much
have a great day and welcome to Windor
thank you very much indeed take enjoy
your visit thank
you here we are Juniper Hill in now who
in the hell would bring an RV all the
way up here and not stay in that studing
hotel look at
it my God that's beautiful wow okay
round to the front
door can't believe they haven't clear
the snow for guest to come
[Music]
in
w
you're kidding me it's locked that's not
very
[Music]
welcoming why would you have a big
mansion that guest can't arrive through
the front [__]
door Jesus who wants to enter through
the back door
Mr Ramsay's here I need you to do room
one right
[Music]
away at least this door's open finally
hello there how are you how are you Mr
Ramsey black Gordon please bloody I'm
Robert Dean Robert Dean we were you over
there I I was at the front door yes okay
this is actually our entrance and in the
winter because of snow ready we have to
keep that locked cuz otherwise the snow
load comes off and kills people kills
people yeah it can have you K anyone so
no where's all this stuff
from
um an aftermath of a antiques Fair yeah
this looks like it could be a beautiful
room you can't tell because it's stuck
with so much clutter that's the
reception desk no my God so what is that
that is our bar right now you are
kidding me this is the bar yes with what
that martinis martinis God bless him H
made of pigs Pig Martini well we have
three rescue P belled pigs you have
three pigs here right what is that for
were you born with this in your mouth
yeah don't I wish honestly actually no
that was a gift from so yeah Robert
obviously loves to show off all these
expensive antiques but as a guest I
don't feel comfortable I feel like I'm
in a museum this is the main formal
dining room this big chair here is for
for one uh just kind of we're known as a
romantic destination and uh just out of
Interest has well we would move the
table move it in for me please
yes
wow so you got a sofa on the table we
thought it was kind of nice to have like
a cozy
banket oh well three US presidents have
dined here oh really which ones uh Teddy
Roosevelt Calvin kulage Teddy Roosevelt
dined in here wow I wanted to try to
give him a little bit of sense of the
history at Juniper Hill wow okay so
that's the dining room well we have two
dining rooms God you must be busy with
two dining rooms well I wish we were
busy bloody h now we have spurts of
being incredibly busy right uh where we
lack is all the other times really yeah
this place looks like a Millionaire's
Mansion not a struggling business I've
got to scratch beneath the surface this
place per week is turning how much we're
lucky if we're doing you know 15,000 a
month what does it cost to keep the
place open 30 ready
yep so you're
losing $200,000 a year yeah it's been a
nightmare we maintained our room rates
thinking that the economy wouldn't be
this long a hall but we've all
experienced those kind of difficulties
and myself including but you you
navigate your way out of that recession
unfortunately my partner lost his job we
expected him to have his job for a
little longer you must have gained a
substantial payoff or retirement it's
all been put into this how much over a
million dollars a million dollars into
this already Yes and does he have an
active role in the business he tries to
maintain the account counting and he
helps just about with everything uh
we're in trouble trouble you'd never
guess from the look of this place it's
more like bucking and palis in skid Road
do you know what um Robert honestly I
like to go straight to my room if you
would mind please all right wow this
place goes on it does it's a largest
colonial revival Mansion in New England
and more paintings and you're in the
Maxwell art Suite which is the original
um okay wow beautiful
room and uh
uh I mean this is uh
this is a beautiful room but why is that
smell I mean seriously it's it does
smell yeah it smell [__] I mean that is
horrific oh my God it smells like
[Music]
sewage coming up Robert staff turn on
him I'm supposed to tell you the truth
right the truth is all I want to know
I'm telling you exactly how I feel and
how the people that I work with feel the
entire staff is ready to walk out you
can talk to him he's your [__] Chef
I'm beyond angry I'm beyond pissed off
and I have to step in how dare you you
still haven't got it get your head out
of your ass and start getting a little
[__] reel excuse me go on then you
pump as
[Music]
[__] I'm at Vermont's Juniper Hill in
and I've just met its owner Robert Dean
II who's filled his hotel with expensive
art and antiques were you born with this
in your mouth but he can't fill his
rooms and his business is struggling
you're losing $200,000 a year it's been
a nightmare and no wonder because
although the room he's put me in looks
nice beautiful room it has one major
drawback what is that smell it smells
like raw sewage we had a plumbing issue
and it's like someone's shot under the
bed and um how much this room goes for
$350 a night
$350 a night for room that smells of
[__] well you're kidding me we haven't
rented it though bloody hell it's been
out of use for um 4 months 4 months
yeah oh come on it has been this is
crazy it is crazy it doesn't make sense
I've got to get out of here it s is
there another room yes I have room too
bloody how I didn't realize $350 to be
caked in
[__] wow it's gorgeous and this one
doesn't smell like crap I'm going to
quickly um unpack and then I would um I
would like to have a um a quick bite of
lunch okay I'll I'll notify the what
time is the restaurant Clos for lunch I
know well we actually don't serve lunch
normally but we're happy to prepare you
something is that a joke we we serve
breakfast and dinner stop stop stop stop
stop you don't actually serve lunch no
the restaurant's closed for lunch yes if
someone request lunch we'll make lunch
for them but could you uh prepare lunch
for me uh yes I can I'll tell the chef
please okay uh thank you
yes not open for lunch Gordon is going
to want lunch huh Gordon wants
lunch what am I supposed to do with that
information h
that was a welcome breath of fresh air
on the back of that disgusting smell of
crap in that room I can't believe it and
the rooms are gorgeous and yet how could
you have a room that has been smelling
for months that bad and then he sticks
me in it what a
muppet despite the Hideous smell in that
first guest
room I've still worked up quite an
appetite hello Hi how are you Barbara
Barbara how glamorous are you how nice
it to see you I have a mad Crush good as
he knows I'm a cougar how old are you
now don't old last week I turned 70
you're kidding me you look a million
dollar you made my year
70 watch out Joan Collins I'm telling
you now bloody
how bab what's wrong with this place
well in a nutshell don't get any people
M like pulling teeth to get my paycheck
you don't get paid it takes forever to
get my paycheck and when I do it's
usually something left out but hold on a
minute you you don't get paid and when
you do not not on time we supposed to
get paid every 2 weeks so what do you
earn a fortnite I made 6,000 this year
$6,000 a year that's ridiculous you know
you got to have the money flowing and
it's almost come to a standstill at this
point my last paycheck was
$48 unbelievable robers obviously got
enough money to fill the guest rooms
with Fine Art and antique furniture but
he doesn't pay his staff and I'm
starving what would you recommend the
crab cakes with a little salad so this
is the dinner menu okay because we're
not open for lunch right and the lamb
sounds great as well you want the lamb
yeah all right darling is this a uh
prefix menu or yeah cuz there's no
prices on here what sort of Resturant
doesn't have prices on the menu It's
like a club for millionaires where if
you have to ask you can't afford it I've
got a supplement of $15 from the lamb
how much is enough enough charge for the
L is Robert
[Music]
nearby
how much is it for three quarters $59
$59 so if we had the lamb it would be 74
people are horrified at the price of the
food this is why a lot of people think
that Juniper Hill is snobbish when we
typically take a reservation we will
tell people it's a three course meal
that's for the residents I'm talking
about a local coming in here we're
reservation only though so nobody walks
in we don't have walk in how can you
expect to appeal to the locals um we
haven't I identify the appropriate
people to come here or hold on what you
mean appropriate people hold on people
who can afford $59 for three courses
appropriate people what a snob where
does he think he is the rits and where's
your table which one's your table uh
well most of the time I eat in our RV
our motor coach say that again oh we
have a motor coach to the side Christ
and where did it come from is it yours
you rent it yeah it's ours we I mean we
owe on it but we bought it and we bought
bought it yeah how much was that over
$100,000
$100,000 you're 3 years away from 50 you
should not be living in an
RV we don't live in um an RV um it is a
motor coach which is the higher end
version of an RV it is that
psychological break for us and it gives
me a place to relax and kind of unwind I
actually love it I could live there the
rest of my life to be honest with you
it's quiet it's clean I suppos if this
place doesn't get fixed then you might
be in there full time
[Music]
yeah
I've just sat down for lunch at the
Juniper H and already I found out the
staff aren't paid on time like pulling
teeth to get my page and the owners live
in a camper
outside how much was that over $100,000
this place is baffling I hope the food
makes more
sense exent
wow where are the crab cakes oh that's
in there under ether are they mini crab
cakes are we uh the chef has decided
that those are the size that he needs to
serve
mhm I mean that tastes Dreadful that
thing tastes sort of washy and soapy at
$20 for that he's as cheap with his crab
cakes as he is with his staff W now for
the Lamb with Robert's ridiculous $15
extra
charge it's um a rack of lamb incrusted
in macadamia nuts uh fresh herbs and a
little bit of Deon mustard it's served
with a honey vinegar reduction it's not
even cooked properly rested and take
that
off I always get nervous when you see
white fat like that on the side of the
[Music]
chop is it do your liking I mean it's
pretty raw in the center you like the
flavor of it though the honey
gar no way too
sweet
mhm I I'm I'm not satisfied with uh the
quality of the foods coming out of the
kitchen I believe our Chef has has a
learning curve to be where he needs to
be thank
you we just lost our other Chef why did
the chef leave I'm supposed to tell you
the truth right the truth is all I want
to know why did the chef leave well her
paycheck she put all everything on her
uh charge cards and and she just figured
she wasn't paid back for what she the
chef bought produce did she did
everything she was the best chef ever
that's Dreadful I'm starving um the
peanut butter chocolate decadence I
could do with some of that pick me up
please thank you God I sh that left
because she had to buy produce on her
own credit card I mean this guy's
priorities are upside down bit like this
Inn hey are you ready this he said he
doesn't care for the sweetness there's
fat around it he didn't care for the
flavor of the honey
girl
[Music]
wellow thank you very much did you cut
it in half cuz it looks like someone's
taking it and where's the other half
gone uh it goes to the another person
who ERS oh know I want my other
half
[Music]
$74 this place is
insane listen half my dessert is missing
if you think I'm spending
$74 for a dessert that is half
[Music]
CAU H it's actually quite nice there is
hope I'm sorry I'm going to say that
that is not a dessert that he made
Barbara made it no somebody else makes
desserts it's ordered like store bought
like through one of our purveyors what
where's the chef he's in the kitchen can
you get him out please yes
what how you doing Chef Julian in my
opinion is not living up to his
potential as a chef he will try to cut
corners and I think Gordon needs to know
these things I've just spent $74 for
three plates of absolute D dated [__]
food crab cakes yes sir you can't put
two little half testicle sized [__]
crab cakes that came from a can there's
bigger [__] cakes chef at a [__]
canopy party my lamb was cold in the
middle the fat was white it was almost
like a mouth full of sugar the best
tasting dish for me was the [__]
chocolate peanut thing that I got served
half a portion that's not even made
[__] in
house what is this there's no Synergy
here there is honestly a lack of
communication often sometimes when I'm
in the middle of doing breakfast service
for the 10 people that we randomly get I
get five texts from him asking me a
question so why are you texting him if
you have a question you should maybe
leave the RV and come out and talk to us
show me those text are you nitpicking
are you trying to control him or you no
I'm trying to make sure I I'm I haven't
been sleeping very well to be honest
with you and uh I've had I've been
beaten down I'll take responsibility for
everything that happens in the kitchen
you don't own the place you own it yet
he's acting more
responsible what do you earn a week if
you don't mind me asking $11,000 before
taxes
$400 Jesus Christ almighty $400 a week
to be the head chef in a luxury hotel
that's insane I mean you're barely
surviving I'm I'm I don't know that I'm
even barely surviving if you're not
happy with your work environment you
should leave are you taking the piss or
is this just an abuse for you what are
you doing to these people this are their
livelihoods this is your
responsibility Rob's World and you're in
an RV 100
Grand everybody is disgusted that you
live in that thing they really are
because it costs so much money and they
can't get their paycheck on
time well that is not the that is not
the part of the issue we are surrounded
by wealth and reminded of poverty at the
same time time because of that RV it's a
symbol to me that RV is a symbol and
it's a symbol that you separating
yourself from everybody else I'd be very
careful about coming down on me too
hard I'm telling you exactly how I feel
and how the people that I work with feel
let me tell you how I feel when you're
in your [__] kitchen all day long and
you're on the goddamn internet instead
of actually trying to perfect a menu and
get a menu how long did I ask for you to
make a menu of your own and if I'm on
the computer usually is I'm trying to
research menus ingredients give me a
break I've given you plenty of breaks I
work very long days and I haven't been
paid in 3 weeks there's only been one
paycheck that I got on time almost the
entire staff is ready to walk out
because they are tired of not getting
paid anything to
[Music]
say no we we do things oh
please it's my first day at Vermont's
Juniper Hill in and the battle between
the chef from the owner I'd be very
careful about coming down on me too hard
has turned what should be a Charming
country in into a war zone I'm telling
you exactly how I feel I work very long
days and I haven't been paid in 3 weeks
there's only been one paycheck that I
got on time almost the entire staff is
ready to walk out because they are tired
of not getting paid anything to
say no we're tired and half the team is
broke I'm beyond angry I'm beyond pissed
off
oh I just got a new [__] ripped to me
Gordon says that I live in a fantasy
world and that uh I live in a million
doll RV while our our our employees
can't pay their bills and all of this
kind of stuff cuz we don't pay them on
time and they're all complaining that
they haven't gotten their paychecks this
time either oh they haven't and he said
that everything is all about me I can't
believe what a mess this place is I've
got to get off this hill for a bit
there's someone I need to
see hello is that lier it's Gordon
Ramsey I've got some questions about
Robert and juner Hill would you mind if
I pop over for 5 minutes
please great I'll see you then thanks
[Music]
later I think the old Chef that quit
will be able to give me some insight
into what's wrong with juniper
Hill
hello how are you good to see you good
to see you come on
in give me a little insight to what it
was like actually working there I have
to say it was very interesting 5 years
uh things were going very very well and
then all of a sudden 2 years into it
they stop answering the
phone Robert I think thought he was too
important to answer the phone or he was
too busy doing other things so
preoccupied and distracted in very very
preoccupied and distracted and not
focused at all on maintain maining his
own business wow I was getting cut out
of a living when they did all this stuff
I used to earn $40 $50,000 in one
restaurant and now I'm down to earning
uh 15 were you paid on time um not very
often wow um did you ever use your own
money to buy things all the time and
then I would have to demand to be paid
back or we were an to open for dinner
it's insane Barbara has been shorted
checks a lot she's barely earing $100 a
week yeah and he won't pair and then if
he had a private party with all his
friends he didn't tip them
you're kidding me no that's just
disgusting I mean that's where I I don't
that you can't do that no you just can't
treat people like that now he's a
confirmed snob and he thinks he's above
the town he thinks he's
Untouchable I'm here to make this place
work um the first thing I'm going to do
is burst his bubble I'd like to be a fly
on that wall but would would you come
back and walk through the doors to have
a look at it at the end of the week and
just come back for dinner no no just
won't go or no I'm not even interested
in getting I I just fear getting in one
more battle with ar or Robert and a sh
after 5 years yeah do you think I've got
a chance of saving it the problem he has
now is nobody will work there you know
I'm there to get this place turned
around um those staff deserve a better
future they do you know I I feel
terrible for them um listen thank you
you're very welcome um appreciate your
time enjoyed it thanks like good to see
you too byebye
[Music]
byebye how sad is that after 5 years of
her life dedic ated to the Juniper Hill
you know she won't even step foot in the
door she doesn't want even see
them the old Chef left because she
couldn't stand it and the current Chef
looks like he's ready to walk too I
wonder if everyone here is feeling the
same frustration Jennifer would you
what's wrong with the place what's wrong
with the place we're lacking uh
paychecks on time paycheck you don't get
paid on time either no we're missing
basic supplies to basic supplies we
don't even have I mean Noel purchased
guest checks for us today so that we've
been using scrap pieces of
paper first name is I'm Ryan Keith Ryan
Keith what' you do I'm the estate
manager here I do all the maintenance on
the house I've done everything here
though that's why he likes me to spread
out my talents to try and help anybody
wherever they need help how's
morale not
good I personally haven't been paid
since the 6th of January here it is the
1st of February that's nearly a month
and you pay the employes before paying
your bills when they've done the work
that's their livelihood I amaz you're
still here working as hard as you are
because staff never need to be treated
like this let me tell you it's always as
if what you're saying to him doesn't get
through because he sees you as not an
equal he treats me like that and that
really bothers me because I feel like
I've contributed a lot it's actually
pretty degrading this is insane coming
up oh my God I uncover the shocking
extent of Robert's Reckless spending
thousands of dollars worth of thousands
of dollars Robert's Dreadful
communication skills cause a meltdown I
said where does this chicken ask him
again Tempest flare excuse me I am the
boss and Robert reveals these True
Colors how dare
you I'm shocked with what I'm finding at
the Juniper Hill in owner Robert wants
to kill his Chef how long did I ask for
you to make a menu of your own and the
rest of the staff want to kill Robert
how's morale not good estate manager
Ryan has told me about some of the
problems but now he wants to show me if
you want to see the root of the problem
let's go to the basement to the basement
yes please Jesus what's in there
everything oh really it's the majority
of it is personal items no even the
shelves are all lying bloody hell look
at this
place oh my
God look at this stuff stereos wine
racks quilts ch chairs tables copper
pans more chairs over there look at
these Robert Prides himself in having to
have the very best of everything Christ
there's enough in here to open three
restaurants is all this stuff still
brand new most of it is brand new
littered with thousands of dollars
Robert's got so much stuff he could
furnish a dozen houses but he doesn't
pay his staff it's crazy where we going
race yourself we're going up to the
office you're kidding me oh no come on
come in this is the office this is
office you're kidding me not at all I
wanted you to Jesus Christ scares me
half to death oh my God this is insane
it would only take a day or two to sort
out this hord as heaven but Robert's
left it in chaos no wonder he spends all
day hiding in his
RV this guy has lost the plot this is
disturbing please tell me there's no
more yes there's more this is where the
pigs are
kept at least they look
happy pigs who live a life of luxury
while everyone around around them
suffers sounds strangely familiar bloody
hell so the owners live out the pigs
live in there's more you check out the
storage units storage units you are
kidding me no oh my
God this one's all personal items look
at oh Jesus I mean I swear to God it's
like a special edition of
Hoarders I mean honestly
wow I'm in shock you know that and this
one all of this entire storage unit is
full of
chairs oh my God look at this stuff
honestly I mean they must be packed with
thousands of dollars worth of hundreds
of thousands of dollars how much stuff
does one
need fluty
hell I can't believe how much stuff
Robert has bought he must have spent a
fortune I've got to meet Robert's
partner Ari and find out why he's
financing all
this welcome welcome my name is Ari it's
a pleasure please um my God so how much
money have you put into this business
personally more less over a million
dollars a million dollars and how much
have you seen back
nothing it was all my my uh Seance
packages my income that I when I was
working and then my retirement plans
rabbit savings are in artwork and
antiques I have supporting this in with
my my savings clearly this is a
beautiful place but putting your entire
life savings into a sinking ship is
insane and with Robert at the helm
treating his staff so poorly I don't see
things getting any
better Robert is in a fantasy world and
I've been struggling all day to get
through to him this place it's Dreamland
a playground for your boyfriend
Robert your biggest problem is not
Juniper Hill your biggest problem is
[__] Robert
I'm at Vermont's Juniper Hill in and
I've just had a difficult conversation
with Robert's partner Ari who seem
strangely unconcerned about how bad
things really are here how much money
have you put into this business
personally well it's over a million
dollar a million dollar and how much
have you seen back
nothing but I've tried to make him see
who's to blame for the problems your
biggest problem is [__]
Robert dinner time is approaching word
has spread about me being at the inn and
the place is bustling good to see you
hello there nice to see you I'm learning
a lot about why the Inn is struggling by
watching Robert and Ari deal with a new
influx of guests anyone with any restant
experience would stagger the seating of
guests but as if they're just welcoming
people to a dinner party at a private
house hello there how are you Robert and
Ari seat everyone at once and the corner
make pretend you're back in 1902 it's
meant to be a relaxed evening and and
that's the recipe for disaster for Chef
Julian and the White staff Chef I'm
making a change on 21 write it down
don't tell me just write it down there
an order are you guys kidding me with
all these orders who said everybody at
once like this best friend we don't know
about
pacing they said
they who's writing the tickets J mean
table four table five some of them have
names on them some of them do not who
wrote that ticket there's not even a
table number on there table four they
just got their lobster where's table 23
they've got I need one person at a time
I need less talking in the kitchen
please T 23 has got no put up in the
window eight people ask me for something
with Julian Haven been slammed by the
owner's Dreadful seating Ari isn't
helping the strained atmosphere with an
awkward art lesson but then like this
this is from 1800 and it was painted for
opera house cuz you know what it
is what is it come on everybody has to
know what that is it's a hanal going
across the albs with the white elephant
everybody should know
[Laughter]
[Music]
that on the other side of the house
Robert's also busy giving a lecture this
is one of the original signs to the
house there's a lot of history here uh
Teddy Roosevelt actually was best
friends with the man or very good friend
with the man who actually built the
house Maxwell art do you you always get
this backed up I mean yes yeah when I
have poor seating Robert has groups of
his friends come in sitting them at once
okay so you're waiting for your starters
then okay well let me uh check on those
for you thank you okay
yeah Robert yes this ticket system is
bollocks you know
that handwritten tickets no time on
there no proper dates no
coordination who trains the front of
house team who's in charge of the
restaurant who who is there I would be
the host and then you'll be the host yes
the chef takes over the kitchen this
place is such a mess clearly Robert has
no idea how to run a hotel yeah so me
too I'm trying to straighten out the
damn drinks cuz they lose we lost 30
something drink oh my
God Robert we lost 30 drinks at least I
often find drinks not written down or
just a lack of follow through and it's a
big problem when we're trying to make
money there's no communication between
the bar and the dining room so people
get served drinks but no one remembers
to charge for them but we're losing big
money no kidding and they're losing
their checks and I'm going crazy trying
to figure out a system they have hardly
any guesss and don't charge the ones
they do have no wonder this place is in
the red how does that happen they're
supposed to write the drinks down and
then apply them to a table and a room
and then they go into the
computer the ticket system is bogus and
as I feared seating everyone at once is
already causing problems for the staff
and the
guests it's not very warm it's burnt
with guest now suffering and the kitchen
falling apart from Robert's ill-managed
seating come on I have to step in um
just just stop
there you have to be [__] kidding me
this Goose liver is burnt to a cinder
stop junior yes sir come around buddy I
know we're in the [__] and we're busy
food's dying in the
window a f salad I mean
honestly it's like a piece of [__]
beef
jerky where's Ari get me Ari urgently I
mean honestly come on guys hello I
stopped that I just said no what is that
what is that VRA oh that's VRA that is
not VRA is not funny guys no that is
it's not funny I mean I know we're in
the ship but does anyone have any
standards here yes well can I see them
can I see something to hold on to cuz
right now I just want to get out of here
I can only be as good as I am with the
tools that I have I'm embarrassed and I
know that I can do better I know the
staff can do better first off no more
[__] tickets in the kitchen give him
10 minutes to catch up okay all right
and Robert is it possible for the first
time put the phone away get your jacket
off and [__] dig deep a little bit
yeah please yeah somebody I'm concerned
that food is in the window and it's just
dying Entre on table six are in the
window Entre send them they shouldn't be
sat here how am I supposed to do
everything back here are you with me I'm
with are you an owner I'm with you are
you an entrepreneur I keep trying to you
know you can talk to him he's your
[__] Chef well when I try to
communicate him he says yeah yeah yeah
no no no no no no I can't do it no he
doesn't [__] find your balls and tell
him you need to talk I found my balls do
I want him to walk out he's not going to
walk out you communicate with him talk
to him there well I have been trying to
so when he finishes it send the [__]
food there's always a third dish not
ready or a fourth dish well it must be
one or two minutes behind but unless you
[__] ask how are you supposed to
[__] know I have been asking I said
where do this chicken so ask him
[Music]
again it's the middle of dinner service
at Juniper Hill in and Chef Julian is
drowning under a flood of orders how am
I supposed to do everything back here
owner Robert has finally decided to get
his hands dirty to try and help but he's
utterly incapable of communicating with
his Chef when he finishes it send the
[__] food there's always a third dish
not ready or a fourth dish well it must
be one or 2 minutes behind but unless
you [__] ask how are you supposed to
[__]
know where is the soup go Julian table
23 I just told you one minute ago I need
frog ra where I know I have it right
behind me
I Julian yes that's what you call
communication it's better communication
that's what you call communication
Robert there's a between interrupting
and no communication and when you
[__] put those Entre up there you
make sure they go you've got to start
stepping up and [__] dictating a
little bit cuz this is just Madness I
agree Jesus Christ it was fuckups from
start to finish and it was a cluster
[__] and Gordon saw that Dreadful with
an owner and Chef so incapable of
communicating with each other it's no
surprise the diners are unhappy and
they're not the only ones while Robert
and Ari are living the dream their staff
are living a nightmare hopefully by
gathering everyone in one room okay I
can get to the root of the problem I've
never seen a hotel an inn in such
disarray there needs to be structure and
there isn't structure it's just like a
scramble it's a
mess there was no order in the kitchen
nobody took responsibility for any one
thing no one has been taught any
standards in any Department
really it's like I'm I'm racing from
thing to thing nobody knows what the
other one's doing there's nobody here
that is in control willing to take
charge I did 40 [__] dinners by
myself tonight I could help you and
you've never asked I can cook the rack
of lamb excuse me bragging about Mak one
plate is nothing to brag about excuse me
excuse me I am the boss you can't call
yourself the boss if you don't [__]
pay
them I mean honestly do you think that's
normal Ari do you think that's the way
to look after your team every pay period
there is a problem with the checks every
pay period there's a problem with the
checks I don't know what the problem is
but I know it's the same two people you
get to know about it first or do you
have to go ask him for your salary I
always ask for it that's absolutely
wrong and the reason is he's lying no no
no he's not lying I would rather have
them wait than write a check that's
going to bounce because I don't how
about telling him it's not going to be
ready rather than having to ask like
some Skiby cap in hand please sir may I
get
paid anybody else have to wait yes mhm
how long 5 days more I have Barbara I
had to wait 5 weeks you had to what I
had to wait 5 weeks before I got a
paycheck five weeks guys you come in and
you work your ass off the least these
two guys can do is pay your [__]
salary on time I don't have a secretary
Gordon I'm sorry I'm trying to
communicate with Brides I'm trying to
send out things I have to have peaceful
time in order to do my work are you
always this pathetic I am not pathetic
well when are you going to stand up and
start showing some respect for your team
and start growing a pair to sort of
understand the mess you're in I
understand the mess we're in I'm
fighting for the team you dug the
[__] hole yes we did and put them in
it so they're [__] they don't have to
work
here oh my God I me you know the bottom
line is how dare you no they don't have
to how dare you how [__] dare you
they don't have to work here oh my God I
I I you disrespectful disgusting man
they don't have to work here I don't
think you realize how [__] lucky you
are CU if it wasn't for 1 2 3 4 5 six of
them you'd be driving that RV miles away
from here Robert definitely needs a
reality check it's life or death right
now and I don't think he actually
realizes what kind of Jeopardy this
place is in it's not all about you
Robert Robert World Robert's bubble
Robert's dream you're not the lord of
the Mana and you're not the Great Gatsby
you're you're Robert it's only me in
here excuse me excuse me go on then you
pump as [__] excuse me don't talk to me
like that but what's wrong with it I
want to know what's wrong with speak to
me like that I'm telling you get your
head out of your ass and start getting a
little [__] re you still haven't got
it that this place is sinking start
paying a little bit more attention to
the guys on the
ground understand how hard it is out
there forget your [__] Antique Road
Show and start from the bottom running
this business you're right there's no
structure it's fragmented the team needs
a leader they need a structure they need
a mentor they need some support and all
they get is nitpicks what kind of
motivation is that all I've heard since
I've been here you're just blaming
people well I'm blaming you for not
taking charge get [__] [__]
real [__]
H next time my Hotel Hell continues
robertsi management spreads like a virus
this time taking down the kitchen what's
the matter with you now do you want to
give me your jacket and I'll do it for
you open up come on you've just shut
down and there's a revelation so
shocking that is disgusting I have to do
something I've never done before I think
my time's done here Gordon left I cannot
stand anymore these bloody lies I just
don't seem that I can do it anym I know
I can't do
it